Here's why I wrote big guns.
I had served in Congress for 16 years
and in those 16 years,
um,
I witnessed a shooting at a university
in Virginia shooting at a movie theater
in Aurora,
Colorado,
shooting at a nightclub in Orlando,
shooting at an elementary school,
uh,
in Connecticut.
And after every single one of those mass
shootings,
I in virtually every one of my
colleagues were confronted with the same
question.
And that is when is congress going to do
something about it?
When will this stop?
Not necessarily when we'll converse to
everything about it,
but just do something,
do universal background checks or,
uh,
some common sense legislation.
And when my constituents in New York
would ask that question,
I knew that the honest answer and the
painful answer was we're not,
congress is not going to do anything
because of the politics that surrounded
the gun safety debate.
And I decided to try and answer that
question in the best way I can.
And that is,
uh,
with snark,
with humor.
And from the very inside of Congress,
I wrote this book during hearings on gun
safety.
I wrote this book on the floor of the
House of Representatives.
I wrote this book on that little balcony
off the floor of the House of
Representatives where members go to rest
while they're not beating each other up,
uh,
inside.
And so this book is really,
it's reflection of what I learned as a
member of Congress.
And it is my way of explaining to
readers why Congress seems so paralyzed
in the face of this mass violence,
uh,
that is affecting so many communities.
And so many of our constituents,
90% of the American people support
strengthened background checks of about
80% of Republicans support,
strengthened background checks.
A majority of NRA members support
And yet when we offered this amendment
for stronger background checks and the
appropriations committee,
it was defeated,
uh,
virtually in a party line vote.
And I was wrestling with this.
Why would members of Congress vote
against something that has such massive
support?
Well,
I learned the lesson and the lesson is
reflected in big guns.
After that,
uh,
hearing,
I went to one of the most sacred places,
uh,
on Capitol Hill,
not a church.
Uh,
but the members only elevator.
And the reason that's sacred,
it's because on the members only
elevator,
you can't have tourists and can't have
the media in,
can't have staff.
And uh,
and so you reach a real level of
confidentiality in that cramped space.
And a bunch of members piled onto this
elevator after the committee meeting and
one of the Republicans on this elevator
said,
why did you try and force us to vote
for,
you know,
for this amendment for background
checks?
And I said,
well,
we didn't force you to do anything.
You voted against it.
A,
my question to you is,
why would you vote against it?
And this member looked at me and said,
I wanted to vote for it,
but I can't go home and explain that
vote to my gun lobby voters.
It would be the end of my career.
That tells you everything you need to
know about why Congress seems so
paralyzed.
It's just say one other thing on this.
After every mass shooting,
the entire country has galvanized.
They want to mobilize.
I mean,
think about what happened after park
land.
You know,
we,
it was so certain that Congress was
going to pass something.
There were rallies and marches and uh,
you know,
everybody was talking about it.
But now we're months from Parkland and
what does Congress done?
Nothing.
I wrote this book.
So Congress people will be reminded that
the solution to this is in the congress
and they have to keep pressuring their
members of Congress to pass meaningful
reforms that will make our kids safer.
I did not want to write big guns as my
personal screed against the,
the NRA and the gun lobby.
Uh,
I thought the best and most credible way
of writing this book was to bring
different characters in with different
viewpoints.
And by the way,
that's what congress is like.
It's different characters with different
viewpoints.
Uh,
and I felt that the best way to tell
this story a was as a satire.
But you know,
all set tire has to be based on a kernel
of truth.
And the truth in this book is that the
fact that Congress does nothing,
the book was actually based on a and
extraordinary and a shocking event after
the Sandy Hook massacre that,
uh,
that killed children in this elementary
school in Connecticut.
I was reading a sitting,
having breakfast right after that.
I was so convinced that we in Congress,
we're finally going to do something when
first graders,
uh,
our gun down,
it would seem that Congress would do
something and my confidence was really
high and I was having breakfast and I
was reading my New York Times one
morning and I came upon this article,
uh,
and I could have sworn that the New York
Times had been infiltrated by the
writers of the onion.
Uh,
because it seems so bizarre.
The story was that while most state and
local governments were actually passing
local ordinances for gun safety,
because Congress would do nothing,
the small city of Nelson,
Georgia decided that they would go in a
different direction.
This small city passed a local ordinance
requiring that every resident of this
city must possess a firearm.
And that was my kernel of truth.
And when I saw that I said,
first I had to figure out whether it was
actually true.
And then when I realized that it was
true,
I decided to build a satire round.
This only instead of making it a
applicable to one small city in Georgia,
I federalized it.
Uh,
I create this law that requires that
every American must own a firearm,
uh,
that works its way through congress.
Now,
if I had just written about the process,
it would be a maybe a slightly lighter
version of the congressional record,
still very boring.
And so I decided I had to weave into it
real characters and I had to make sure
that the characters express different
viewpoints because the gun debate is in
Philly is influenced by so many
different viewpoints.
Uh,
so it was important to me that this
story reflect both sides of the issue,
but also make the point that Congress
will not act because of the politics
that surrounds us and the fear that so
many of my colleagues have,
uh,
not that their constituents are going to
be shot,
uh,
but that their careers may be ended if
they take on the NRA and the gun lobby.